ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
je suis interpellé par des dirigeants de
TPE de ma circonscription qui sont très
inquiets de la situation actuelle cette
inquiétude est plus largement partagée
par les 6 millions d'indépendants et de
dirigeants de pmetpe qui ont peur du
lendemain avec l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie nos PME TPE sont au bord de la
faillite la France produit son
électricité à 50 euros le mégawattheure
grâce à notre parc nucléaire unique en
Europe mais les entreprises l'achètent
au prix délirant de 600 700 euros les
mécanismes de protection mise en place
par votre gouvernement pour les
entreprises sont largement insuffisants
et les mesures européennes n'en
finissent plus de tarder on ne peut pas
dire aux entreprises de ne rien signer
comme l'a dit le président de la
République il y a un mois et dénoncé à
longueur d'interview des prix fous et ne
pas défendre concrètement nos
entreprises
les mesures proposées aujourd'hui sont
totalement insuffisantes les TPE sont
exclus aujourd'hui du dispositif seuls
certaines PME y sont éligibles au
demeurant selon des critères trop
complexes on ne peut plus attendre il en
va de la survie de nos entreprises il en
va de notre compétitivité nationale nous
demandons l'élargissement du bouclier
tarifaire à toutes les PME et TPE avec
des critères simples et juste par
ailleurs 700 000 TPE ont eu recours au
PGE qui ont pris fin le 30 juin 2022 un
indépendant devra consacrer en moyenne
564 euros par mois pour son
remboursement soit plus de 6% de son
chiffre d'affaires pendant quatre ans
auquel s'ajoute le remboursement des
dettes sociales contractées auprès de
l'URSSAF soit au total d'imensualités
comprises entre 500 et 1000 euros la
Cour des comptes évalue à 160 000 le
nombre d'entreprises très fragilisées
par cette situation
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence quel
dispositif global d'aide comptez-vous
mettre en place et avec quel calendrier
pour donner les moyens à nos entreprises
d'affronter ces chocs successifs